that's part of itcs
where it features
junior researchers who are
close to graduating
on either end either graduated a few
years ago or are graduating soon or are
graduating this year so we're lucky
today to have an exciting lineup of 14
young researchers who are going to sort
of tell a little bit about themselves
i've really put little to no restriction
on you know what what they must say or
do so we'll see what they have and how
they choose to present themselves
we're going to start in about uh in
about 30 seconds
yeah and in fact our first presenter is
going to be pretty sony uh pratik is
at carnegie mellon and
yeah he'll be our first presenter and
we'll take it from there uh you can feel
free to start in
we're gonna be on a very tight schedule
you can start in three
two
one
take it away
hey hi everyone uh my name is pratik i'm
a currently a postdoc at carnegie mellon
university uh and i'm looking for 10
year track positions in theory and cyber
security this year uh my main research
is in cryptography
uh so cryptography is everywhere today
it's used every time your phone connects
to the internet and anytime you use a
credit card and in fact it's now
becoming an integral part to more
advanced and complex computing
technologies like cloud computing secure
messaging and blockchains
so let's look at the example of
blockchains right abstractly it's a
distributed ledger where users are
allowed to post data and miners are
responsible for maintaining the ledger
according to some predefined rules
and blockchain needs a lot of advanced
cryptography in fact blockchains have
been a driver for a good fraction of
recent innovations in cryptography
despite this one of the major challenges
we face today in blockchains is that of
scalability
an integral component of current
blockchain systems are proofs and here
proved overheads are becoming a major
bottleneck in a primary challenge to
address scalability issues
there has been some exciting work on
optimizing time overheads of the brewer
but proverbs memory overheads have been
largely ignored and my work identifies
this and gives zero knowledge groups
where proverbs memory and time overheads
are minimal
as excessive memory usage inherently
contributes more to time we believe our
result which focuses on memory
consumption provides an approach to
obtain better scalability
blockchains are often viewed as
consumers of cryptography and this is
the view i presented in the previous
slide as well but recently i've been
looking into blockchains as an enabler
for doing cryptography
and in fact you can do a lot of new
cryptography using blockchains and for
to listen to more about this you should
come to uh session number 15 at ipcs
tomorrow where we use blockchains to
give new cryptography
beyond connections with blockchains i've
also worked on building crypto systems
that are secure against stronger attacks
for example man in the middle attacks
are notorious and extremely difficult to
handle in numerous cryptographic
settings my work here builds protocols
that are resilient to such attacks
another example here is of block ciphers
which are pervasively deployed
cryptographic algorithms in practice
here my work tries to understand
formalizes security for blockchains in
stronger settings where the adversary
knows the underlying key
so beyond this i want to conclude with a
couple of future works that i'm very
excited about
uh so note that the recent importance of
zero knowledge groups uh makes it uh
important to solve prover horrors right
so one approach here is to whether we
can use the power of parallel computing
in order to improve the prower overheads
secondly i want to explore new
connections between cryptography and
blockchains for example there are new
cryptography for blockchain applications
uh like adapter signatures and
contingency proofs what's the next one
similarly there are numerous properties
of blockchains that enable cryptography
one of which i presented to you in the
previous slide what is a new one that we
could try to explore and get better
cryptography that's my time thank you uh
back to the host
uh yeah thanks uh where you're actually
a minute fast in the sense that uh it's
three minutes that you had four but uh
there's
if there's anything else you want to say
go for it
or if there's any questions
yeah i mean i think i i said as much as
i wanted to say cool very efficient uh
in that case uh we can get uh setups
early for the next uh participant uh
next up uh
is kiran vadrahali at uh
uh columbia
so feel free to share whenever
cool and yeah feel free to start
whenever you want
okay am i unmuted oh good okay
yeah hi i'm karen vodrahali i'm a final
year phd candidate at columbia and i'm
advised by alex and dhoni and daniel sue
and i work on the theory and practice of
machine learning i'm currently looking
for either industry research positions
or postdoctoral positions
so let me tell you a bit more about my
research
so there's two kind of main directions i
work on one is resource efficient
learning where you know i'm concerned
about sample and time complexity of
various kinds of models in particular
sparse models
low rank models and i'm also working on
streaming settings a bit more recently
and the second direction i call
controllable and interpretable agents so
one thing will be something i call
platform design which i'll talk a bit
about more later uh online and
reinforcement learning and
algorithmic game theory and i'll give a
little vignette of one of my works from
each of these areas
and in future work i'm interested kind
of in
the directions in both of these areas
and i've also worked on many
applications and continue to be
interested in applications
so first i'll talk about resource
efficient machine learning so one
challenge in modern ml is that we deal
with very very large models like these
giant deep neural networks
so one approach that we can go for
mitigating the sample and time
complexity is to look at low rank models
where we replace the parameter matrices
uh with low rank approximations okay
so i have a recent work with uh many
people from google which is in
submission and we'll be on our content
very soon
and here we work on learning low rank
deep models by replacing full rank
layers with low rank parameters and one
question that's of important is how do
you initialize
and the standard way of doing it is to
just use the svd of some full rank
initialization of the weights
we present non-linear kernel projection
or nkp
which is essentially replacing the
minimization of the frobenius distance
with the minimization of some
kernel distance which takes the
non-linearity in the layers into account
and we demonstrate empirical gains over
the svd
we also give a provably efficient
optimal algorithm for the nkp in the
setting where uh we're solving it as a
learning problem uh we give an efficient
learning algorithm and we demonstrate
both theoretically and practically that
our method outperforms the svd
initialization and especially along the
axes of
larger width networks and
for lower rank approximations
okay
so the second i'm going to talk about
platform design which is joint work with
crystals papa dimitri and miguel is
janakakis
so here
we're dealing with the economics of the
online firm so online firm is a company
like google facebook etc and they want
to create services
which bring users convenience and
knowledge but also so that the users
give them data so they know users don't
pay directly with money they pay with
data
and we want to understand um how the
online firm can go about designing such
platforms
okay
so we start with a simple model where
the agent lives in some markov chain
called life
and they go between the various states
and the online firm has to decide what
platforms to build to get the agent to
give them their data so they can create
a platform like say google maps
and then the agent can opt into maps
change the transitions of their markup
chain presumably for the better while
simultaneously giving up say their
location data
so we this problem is modeled as a
stackelberg game where the designer
moves first
and gives platforms to the agent
the agent now faces a markup decision
process and mdp and plays optimal
behavior and so we model this as a
bi-level mdp optimization problem and we
study the computational complexity of
this problem and in general uh it don't
be hard when platforms are viewed as
complements
uh but it's efficient to approximate in
a special case when you view the uh
platforms as substitute goods
and uh there's many many directions for
future all right thanks kieran uh your
time's up uh if you could stop sharing
and uh talia eden is next at mit
talia
please feel free to share whenever
cool
and take it away
okay hi
oh sorry hi um my name is talia aiden
i'm a postdoc at mit and at boston
university and i'm looking for
tenure-track positions um
in theory and graph algorithms
and my study is about sublinear time
algorithms where what we do is we trade
some we assume that
in subliminal time we assume that
the algorithm does not is not allowed to
go over the entire input rather just
sample it in as few as possible
locations because it's maybe the input
is too large
and the goal is to get a close to
accurate uh answer so what we do is we
trade accuracy for efficiency
um
and
it means that we assume that the graph
is too large to be stored locally so it
sits somewhere remotely and we can only
access it through queries and engineers
and the goal is to minimize the number
of queries to the object to the graph
and the running time
and in this setting i study motive
analysis where more graph motifs are
small subgraphs that record throughout
the network
for example this could be small stars or
clicks or even
um or even
arbitrary subgraphs and by looking at
the statistics of these small subgraphs
we can gain information about the local
structure of the graph so for example if
you're looking at clicks we can learn
about the community and structure of the
graph or um learning about the star
distribution we can learn about the
decreased distribution so really motive
gives us information about the global
structure even though there are
localized structures
more generally sorry for more
complicated examples in social networks
we can learn about missing friendships
in chemistry imported molecules may be
missing what's in maps and also
in um in biology we can see that uh this
is a four this is a poding network and
we can see that clicks correspond to
folding sites so really by learning
about motifs we can learn about the
structure of the graph and this is the
motivation for my study so in this
telling i studied a lot of motifs and
when i started my phd
what was known is how to approximately
count edges and styles in the cuff in
general graphs
so we first extended these results to
approximately counting triangles and
click uh and then we also consider these
results in bounded velocity graphs which
are graphs that have more structure and
gave improved results uh for these types
of questions
and one notion that came up a lot in
this works is the notion of uniform
sampling of counting their uniform
snapping so we also initiated the study
of uniform sampling in general graphs
gave results for a
uniform sampling of edges in sub-linear
time these are the first results of this
sort and we also extended it again to
triangles and clicks um
and then we also gave results for
sampling multiple clicks which were
later shown to be optimal right at the
control
um so this is the type of work i've
been doing
um
and also sometimes when you go from
theoretical results to practice some new
considerations arise for example you
don't control the query model
or you want to use more structure on the
graph to get improved results for
real-world graphs so i also do
practical algorithms meaning meaning
algorithms for real world networks
um so we have to summarize uh
my interests i did a lot of work on
sublinear time motif counting initiated
the study of some linear time motive
sampling and also i have works in other
computational models and other types of
questions
um so these are kind of the set of
results i had from as subliminal motive
counting this is for sampling and for a
subset of this result i want the 2020
best dissertation world
and also in other models i first studied
these types of questions in other models
of computation as the massively parallel
computation this distributed
algorithms congest and learning
assistant and also studied other results
other questions like graph property
testing of graphs and boolean functions
thank you talia your time is up next up
is dihan please screen share whenever
you're ready
and zihan is at the university of
chicago
okay go ahead okay um
so hello everyone i'm jihan tan i'm a
six-year phd student at university of
chicago so i'm graduating this year and
only applying for postdocs
and my advisor is julia detroit from tti
so um
so my research mainly focused on graphs
so i did a research on all kinds of
graph algorithms and most of my time was
spent on classical graph functions in
the past five years so for the classical
graph algorithms
it is not the vertex cover type it's not
the minimum independent set type but the
highlights the the keywords that i want
to highlight are crossing number
exclude degree theorem and flow cut and
distance specifiers so it is really the
structural type of the graph algorithms
that i work on okay and in the past one
year and a half i'm also switching to
graph algorithms on this new computation
models like the distributed model
dynamic model and the sub linear
and also working on the graph algorithm
in this new computational models and
also interested in graph in the
intersection between the graph
algorithms and other related fields okay
so basically one word if you want to
remember me is graphs
okay
so i would like to
highlight one result or actually a
sequence of two papers on crossing
number
okay so what is the crossing number
problem the input is just a graph
and the output is a drawing of the graph
in the plane okay and the drawing is a
mapping that maps the vertices into
points and map adjectives into curves
connecting the endpoints so for example
if your input graph is k5 i click on
five
on five vertices then this is the join
of k5 in the prime and this drawing has
only one crossing so this is an
intersection between these two curves
and we know that k5 is not a planar
graph so crossing number as of a graph
is defined to be the minimum crossing
number of any minimum number of
crossings in any drawing of the graph so
the crossing number of k5 is one
so
what is known about this problem so uh
it has a very long history it was
proposed by turin in 1944 and by the
time of 2014 already 700 papers have
been written on it and in general case
we basically know nothing the strongest
hardness result is ap x hard and there's
no non-true approximation and we do have
one beautiful result about this crossing
number which is this crossing number
inequality it basically says that if the
graph is moderately dense then the
crossing number has to be very high and
the most interesting part of this
problem is really when the crossing
number is small but whether or not you
can find a good drawing with small
number of crosses so it's reasonable to
look at the boundary degree graph which
is indeed the main research direction in
the past 10 years
and the strongly strongest negative
result in this case is still only akx
heart
and
the approximation algorithm
is improved uh for uh from the other end
approximation uh like
more than ten years ago to enter the
point nine ten years ago and recently to
squirt of it uh like two three years ago
and our result
is that we obtain an interlude of one
approximation to the crossing number on
boundary degree graphs so this
significantly improved the previous
approximation in this first
subpolynomial subpolynomial
approximation algorithm for this problem
okay that's um i want to say and uh
uh graphs my research is on graphs thank
you
cool thanks uh you have another uh 20
seconds roughly if you want but uh oh
yeah okay i can keep it uh
yeah thanks jihan next up is ian mertz
uh ian is at the university of toronto
can you hear me yeah we can hear you
great all right perfect
uh so hi thanks for coming uh my name is
ian uh the things i think about nowadays
are composition theorems and uh getting
postdocs so hopefully you'll think about
them too after this
so uh just quickly a composition theorem
is the following you have two functions
that you care about f and g and you have
some way of composing them or combining
them into some super function and the
question is is it just is it easier to
solve the super function than to solve
the two uh individual functions by
themselves
so
in terms of combining there's two ways
that i uh that most people usually think
about call them sequential and parallel
so in the sequential way uh this one
over here you take a copy of f and you
replace each of its variables with a
copy of g on some fresh set of variables
uh sequential because it seems like you
have to solve g to solve f
and then in the parallel world you just
have f and g on some separate set of
variables and you want to solve both of
them and output their answers so you
can't cheat your way out of solving g
you actually have to output both answers
but if you do some pre-processing or you
know alternate or something maybe you
can save some time or other resources
and in terms of resources when you
specify a composition theorem you also
have to talk about what you're trying to
save and the way the ones that i think
about are formula depth
uh and turing machine space so you've
got a space mounted turning machine
uh
so you can take any combination of these
or anything else you want uh the two
that i care most about are uh well so
the first one is you take the sequential
method of composing and you look at
formula depth and this is connected to
questions about polynomial time versus
uh formula size nc1 and here the answer
should be that no you can't save
anything uh your depth of your compose
function should be roughly the sum of
your depths of the other two at least
that's what i think and that's what i've
been working on
so
there's lots of applications to well
formula size is a major open problem by
itself but there's also connections to
like metacomplexity especially improved
complexity and uh if you come to a top
of my talk on thursday you can see some
new connections between these uh lifting
theorems as they're called and uh the
sunflower lemma so there's some
connections to combinatorics that run
pretty deep
and the other setting i care about is
you take the parallel method and you ask
the question for space
and here i actually think the answer
should be yeah you can save quite a bit
so
this uh has a lot of applica uh
applications in just a classical space
bounded complexity we uh recently showed
and uh
this is online you can recently uh we
recently showed that um you can get
better algorithms for this problem
called tree evaluation which we
suspected would be able to separate log
space from paid turns out there's some
pretty good space algorithms and uh
they're only getting better so there's
classical space there's this meth mode
called catalytic space uh which i think
is super cool about borrowing memory and
we have some work coming out pretty soon
about amortized space so
uh i think that uh these composition
theorems are very interesting and i hope
that you will grow to think about them
and if you're too busy to think about
them then consider hiring an expert like
me
that's it thanks
perfect uh thanks ian you're actually
ahead of time um
in which case we can go ahead with the
next speaker who is pedro paredes pedro
is at carnegie mellon and you can feel
free to start whenever you're ready
all right can you hear me yeah i can
hear you great all right
um hello everyone my name is pedro perez
i am a fifth year phd student art
targeting melon and i'm advised by
professor ryan o'donnell and i'm
currently looking for post-doc positions
or uh equivalent positions
okay so a summary of my research
research interests my research focuses
mainly on spectrograph theory through
randomness and coding theory um
concretely i work on graph expansion uh
properties and applications meaning i
work on problems of the following nature
how can we build uh graphs or objects
are expanding
or how can we analyze the expansion
properties of graphs or objects that are
drawn from random distributions of
different natures and also how to apply
these things to different areas and this
ends up having applications in so many
areas of theory including like i
mentioned coding theory and
pseudo-randomness and also spectrograph
theory
um more broadly i'm also interested in
sort of other aspects of
theory like complexity theory
combinatorics and random matrix theory
these end up being related to the things
that i already work on but i also want
interested in these questions in a more
broad sense
um
some of the work that i'm currently
doing and and i'm planning on doing is
uh on high dimensional expenders where
my goal is to sort of uh extend some of
the ideas and some of the things that
i've worked on for graphics pension for
these high dimensional objects that have
been very uh popular in the theory
community lately and they've been um
they've led to so many new results in
different areas uh and i'm mainly
interested in problems related to
construction of these um
high dimensional expanders but also in
problems related to
random
high dimensional expanders or how to
provide for example a distribution of
high dimensional objects simplicial
complexes that have properties of high
dimensional expansion i'm also
interested in spectral algorithms for
example problems related to
sparsification of graphs or
sparsification hypergraphs and this is
something else that i have been thinking
about uh as well as some other problems
related to uh the previous things that
i've mentioned like graph expansion
i also wanted to mention that i'm also
interested and experienced in teaching
but uh i'm mainly doing uh research
uh okay i wanted to sort of give you
very briefly some um
a selection of some of my results that
i've worked on so far
one of them is this result on explicit
neuraminus and graphs and where we
showed how to construct uh these new
remington graphs which are near optimal
spectral expanders uh this is joint work
with surround mohanty who's a phd
student at berkeley and my advisor ryan
o'donnell um and this work we extended
some some tools that uh already sort of
existed in this area uh and uh we had to
deal with problems related to
probability theory to uh combinatorics
and so on to sort of build this this uh
this um
framework to build graphs that are uh
expanding using lifting theorems so this
is one of the results that i worked on
uh recently uh we then sort of expanded
on this results uh and we
have this new result that is gonna is uh
set to be published at idcs this year uh
which are on explicit a billion lifts uh
this is sort of a generalization of the
result from the from the paper that i
just mentioned where we showed that
these objects call or these products
called a billion lifts when we do that
in random they preserve sparkle
expansion
and the main reason why we wanted to do
this is because we could use this to
apply this in different areas mainly in
the construction of different types of
ldpc codes and this led to good
quasi-cyclic ldpc codes which are a
family of
error correcting codes that are actually
used in practice
and are really popular nowadays but also
a family of quantum ldpc codes this work
has been recently subsumed by uh uh this
work on asymptotically optimal ldpc
codes uh but our work uh showed sort of
like a a subset of that result i guess
um by expanding some of these um
by showing these properties about a
building links uh so this is joint work
with uh fernando geronimo uh geronimo
mattel ryan o'donnell and uh
okay and that's it thank you very much
perfect timing pedro uh i'm just gonna
cut you off okay next up is
alex block at uh purdue
alex uh feel free to share and take it
away whenever you are ready
oh sorry give me one second yep
i'll be quick so it's okay
let me share our screen
okay okay can you see the slides uh it
seems to be a bunch of diagonal lines i
can't see anything uh uh-oh okay
uh
okay uh do you want to skip me i think
yeah i know you want to go next
i need you
sure
sure go ahead we can we've got a little
bit of a
bit of a leeway so it's okay we can
handle this all right all right go ahead
i don't have that much to say um i'm
inesh i'm from carnegie mellon um i'm
co-advised by praveesh patari and david
woodruff
if you take them
hopefully this will be our genealogy
tree in a few months
i'm a fifth year phd student and i'm
looking for a postdoc my research and
address are essentially the reunion of
the research interests of david pravesh
but in particular robust algorithm
design
the summer squares hierarchy uh and
numerical in the algebra i'm also mainly
interested in algorithmic problem
problems that show up at you know any
any tcs domain and if it has an
interesting favor i'd be happy to think
about it
um okay so let me say a bit about robust
statistical models which has been a
main theme in my phd thesis so far um so
here
instead of
just given id samples from a
distribution you're given id samples but
then some fraction of the samples are
corrupted by an adversary
um and this
this this model was initially studied by
tokyo huber back in the 60s in the
statistics community and it's used to
capture systematic outliers and error
and there's been decades of work when
designing statistical estimators that
are robust in in such a sense but these
are typically not efficiently computable
in high dimensions and there really has
been a lot of work like multiple
textbooks
estimators where most of my work focuses
on oscillators that are efficient in
high dimensions so let me give some
examples of how to fit
models to data when the online data is
corrupted in this malicious model that i
just defined
um some examples of these include
learning mixtures of arbitrary gaussians
um clustering the non-spherical mixtures
beyond just gaussian distributions
um regression
and list decodable subspace recovery and
regression where here instead of just a
small fraction of your data being
corrupted
potentially you know majority of your
data is corrupted and your
and your goal is to output a small list
another example is like fitting a dual
neural network which doesn't exactly
work in this model but it has other
robustness guarantees
okay and the other theme in my research
has been uh designing algorithms for
numerical algebra here the focus is
slightly different we want to design
really efficient algorithms
for things like dimensionality reduction
where you in fact don't even read most
of the data so these are sublinear
algorithms and some examples of these
include
algorithms for low rank approximation
when you're promised that the input
matrix is positive semi-definite um here
you don't even read most of the matrix
and can output a low rank approximation
a similar result for distance matrices
another problem that i really like is to
test
whether a matrix is positive sorry
definite without reading uh most of the
entries of the matrix so this this work
addresses this problem
um then i've looked at generalizations
of you know low rank approximation and
pca to other unitarily invariant norms
you know not just for being as an
operator norm but an arbitrary shadow
and b norm
um as well as designing algorithms uh
which again don't read the entire matrix
but work for you know kernel meters
which again have structure so the
overall theme here is like if you're
underlying matrix and structure can you
exploit it without reading all of the
matrix and come up with hyper efficient
algorithms okay uh that's all i have i
don't need the rest of the time thanks
perfect thanks a lot i naish uh yeah
that was great thanks for picking up
real quick uh next up is uh arielle
schwartzman so feel free to share
whenever you're ready arielle is at uh
dimax
uh hi can you
see my screen to you we can't see your
screen shared i don't feel pretty sure
sorry it seems the most having
submissions
yep
if you want we can put you at the end as
well if uh
yeah that'd be good okay uh are you
there and ready
yes i'm here let me cool all right let's
go with saeed uh who is
sharifi malva jaredi who's at university
of pennsylvania take it away
[Music]
can you see my screen now
yeah it looks great okay
so i'm sayit i'm a phd student in the
statistics department of the university
of pennsylvania where i'm advised by
michael kearns and aaron roth
and i am on the market for faculty
positions
my research is on enforcing ethical and
social constraints in algorithm
development and so far i have mainly
focused on three topics under this
umbrella of ethical algorithm design
these topics are algorithmic fairness
and machine learning
privacy preserving data analysis
and the last one is machine unlearning
or data deletion which i'm going to tell
you briefly about today
so machine learning learning is
basically motivated by the right to be
forgotten of gdpr which says that if
you're a user of a company say facebook
and if at any time for any reason you
want your data to be deleted from
facebook you can have that request and
facebook must immediately delete your
data
but it is easy to delete data from
databases but the more important
question here is that how do we delete
remove the influence of these data
points from the models that have used
those data in the training procedure
and when you think about this problem
the very first solution that comes to
mind is that we can remove these data
points from our databases and we can
retrain our models from scratch on these
updated data sets
but as you can imagine retraining from
scratch can can be computationally
expensive
and this brings us to this question
can we do better than retraining can we
design a deletion or unlearning
algorithm which is much faster than the
retraining procedure and also the
outputs of this unlearning algorithm is
are indistinguishable from the outputs
that would have arisen from the
retraining procedure
so in some sense unlearning algorithms
are supposed to mimic the retraining
procedure for us but hopefully with much
less computational cost
so with that intuition in mind let me
move on to formalize a model and a
definition for an unlearning algorithm
so suppose that training time
we have some data set d training data
and we use some training algorithm a to
train a collection of models
and let's call the algorithm that we
will use to perform deletion for us by r
sub a so at deletion time r sub a gets a
deletion request
and also it gets any auxiliary
information from previous round that can
help facilitate the deletion procedure
for us as inputs and it outputs a new
collection of models and these deletion
requests arrive sequentially over time
now let's see what would happen if we
wanted to retrain in every round we
would basically remove these data points
from the original training data sets and
we run the same training algorithm on
these updated data sets so for example
for the first deletion we removed data
point z1 from the original training data
set d and then we run the same algorithm
a on that data set
now we have all the ingredients to
formally define what we mean by an
unlearning algorithm we say that r sub a
is an unlearning algorithm for a
if the distribution of the models output
by r sub a on the left hand side is
equal to the distribution of the models
output by the retraining procedure on
the right hand side
so if r sub a is an unlearning algorithm
for a according to this definition
and if r sub a is faster than the
returning procedure then we would
strongly prefer to use r sub a instead
of the returning procedure that's the
high level idea
and that was a brief introduction to
machine learning i've done a couple of
works in this domain
in the first one we focus on the convex
interior core risk minimization setting
and we developed unlearning algorithms
that only use gradient updates
and in the second one we use techniques
from differential privacy to design the
first data deletion algorithms that
unlike some prior work have rigorous
guarantees against adaptive lead shows
and deletion sequences and these
algorithms work in the most general
non-convex settings
so here are the my papers on machine
learning and feel free to reach out to
me if you have any questions thank you
very much
perfect thanks a lot saeed uh perfect
timing and thanks for picking up on
notice next up is prantargoshu that
dartmouth college
go ahead whenever you're ready
uh
front door
yeah yeah i can hear and see go ahead
yep and you can see your shirt running
yeah we can see your screen shared
yeah oh
yeah
uh hello yeah yeah you're fine go ahead
whatever okay
okay hi i'm prandtl ghosh from dartmouth
college i'm a fifth year phd student i'm
advised by yamik chakravarthy and i
expect to graduate in spring 2022
and i'm mostly looking for postdoc
positions starting summer or fall 22
so my research area is in the data
streaming uh setting so here
we receive an input as a sequence of
elements they want to a
m let's say and we want to maintain a
summary of the data and we want to
output a correct our answer at the end
of the stream
to uh some problem
and our goal is to optimize the space
usage
now my focus is on graph streaming and
here
a graph problem uh is what we focus on
and the graph is built by a sequence of
edge insertions and deletions and for
the problems we want to solve are
something like uh is the graph connected
or how many triangles are there in the
graph or
let's say you want to proper coloring of
the graphs
i have also considered variants of the
data streaming model for example
adversarially robust streaming where
instead of fixing an input streaming
headphones and adversary adaptively
decides it it sends us a stream element
a1 receives an output to the current
state o1 and decides the next stream
element a2 this gets the next uh output
o2 and so on and so forth
so
uh then another
variant that i have considered here is
called annotated streaming setting here
the uh
it's a amplification of stair data
streaming and approver verified system
where the prover knows the entire stream
and it sends the answer to the problem
along with the proof to the user which
is who acts as a verifier and wants to
collect information from the data so as
to
uh just verify the answer and proof and
we would like to optimize the
truth usage
the proof size and the space usage in
this set
so now
my research is basically on
understanding the space complexities of
various graph problems
in this data stream setting and its
variance and streaming and robust
treatment
and this involves designing space
efficient algorithms and also proving
the minimum space requirements or
showing lower bounds
so let me
briefly go over some of my contributions
so i have
given the first foundation algorithms
for some classical dietary graph
problems like topological sorting or
feedback accept
and i have also
given graph coloring algorithms using
very small number of colors
as uh using uh something a new novel
parameter called the degeneracy of the
graph
i have designed uh emulator streaming
the protocols for certain graph problems
some of which were these are conducted
to be impossible and some of which are
optimal are
probably optimal for those problems
i have also and this in this itcs the
paper we have uh we i have designed
robust coloring algorithm new techniques
and uh
lower bounds i have shown
limitation results of certain flavors
for example for certain problems i have
shown that there is no sublinear space
algorithm possible for example
order delta coloring in robot streaming
or kappa plus one coloring and standard
streaming
i have shown that existing algorithms
for certain problems are probably
optimal for example topological sorting
in tournaments i have shown that natural
generalizations of certain problems for
example uh if we take coloring from
standard to robust setting or instead of
delta plus one you consider karma plus
one coloring by couples the degeneracy
of the graph then these problems become
provably harder
and against certain standard relaxations
of problems for example considering
random order streams instead of
adversarial order doesn't make this
problem easier
all right thank you uh
that's all the time we have um next up
is ying kai li yin kai is at
northwestern university feel free to
screen share and take it away whenever
you're
ready thanks
okay hi everyone uh my name is in kylie
from last wednesday university uh i'm
currently looking for both postdoc and
tenure track positions i'm going to talk
about mechanical sound with the
indulgence information
and my research is in the intersection
between computer science and economics
in the cs side my focus is on the design
of good algorithms in complex
environments
note that in many applications of
interest those algorithms are going to
interact with strategic agents and those
agents can manipulate the input to the
algorithms for the interest of their own
and moreover
those strategic agents often rely on
their privacy information for making
better decisions
and crucially the information that the
agent have as endogenous means that what
type of information the agents choose to
acquire for making better decisions
often depends on the choice of the
algorithm i had my research as seen in
this inter discipline area on designing
good algorithm for systems within dodge
information
and
a sequence of papers we are going to
illustrate that this industrial
submission is actually a crucial
ingredient for designing good algorithm
for various applications
this is the illustrator by showing that
actually many insights from the custom
mechanical design where we don't
consider indulgent information actually
fail for those applications within
budget information
and to resolve this issue we are going
to propose several novel ideas for
designing good algorithms when there are
industrial information
to give you a more concrete idea let's
consider the foreign example of the
information position
the classical work has focused on the
characterization of scoring rules which
is essentially designing the word
functions of the agent to incentivize
them to
report their product information to the
designer
an important ingredient missing from
those previous work is indulgence
information means that those information
is nothing but with agents as agents
need to actually exit costly effort to
acquire high quality information and
then actually the designer would prefer
the agent to access the effort and
report high quality information instead
of doing no effort and to report some
garbage information
and here's the goal here is to design
school rules that actually incentivize
the agent to exit the effort and then
report the according to
which and in our paper we are able to
show that when there are multiple tasks
uh and very intuitive
approach as from the
design without indulgence mission is to
score each type separately and the
elastic information from the agent
separately from each task and we are
able to show that this design of
separate scoring is actually pretty bad
for incentivizing effort
and we are able to propose a very novel
strong group that actually links
incentives across to different tasks and
these incentivizing agents to exit
effort
on as many tasks as possible and we are
able to show that this is approximately
optimal in any situations
and this example illustrates the
importance of considering budget
information for designing good
algorithms
and finally i would like to briefly talk
about the other directions i'm also
interested in
for example i'm interested in designing
simple mechanism with practical
implications that are approximately
optimal and has robust performance
guarantees in various segmentations and
i'm also interested in designing good
learning algorithms the online branch
will expanded feedbacks and a good
mechanism for strategic agents have
repeated interactions
and that's all thanks everyone perfect
thank you uh yunkai uh perfect timing
next up is chris jones at the university
of chicago uh take it away whenever
you're ready chris
okay thanks hi
uh my name is chris jones yeah as
mentioned i'm at the university of
chicago i'm advised by aaron patechen
and i'm looking for postdoc positions
so here i've shown some of the things
that i like to think about this is just
a word cloud of terms that are related
to my research
uh yeah if i had to summarize it i'd say
that i'm really interested in generic
powerful mathematical techniques and how
they can be applied to computer science
so i really like math but i like
computer science more
so i just want to zoom in to a couple
different regions of this picture and
tell you about some of my research and
why i'm interested in these areas and
what are some future questions that
we're considering
so the first area is kind of this
central area
the sum of squares hierarchy so sum of
squares lower bounds is one probably the
most important thrust of my research in
the recent few years
what is the sum of squares algorithm
it's this super powerful semi-definite
programming algorithm
and
it's been interesting because in the
last couple years it's led to a lot of
breakthrough algorithms and in
particular in two areas
the first one is in statistics
where we've got new algorithms for like
tensorfca and robust linear regression
that really match uh predictive
guarantees and
this paradigm has led to these
breakthroughs and the second is
constraint satisfaction problems where
some squares is conjectured to be
optimal under the unique game's
conjecture and it's also led to a lot of
interesting new algorithms for unique
games for example
so my work is mostly focused on lower
bounds against this super powerful
algorithm
so for example we showed some lower
bounds against some particular problems
and the technique we use to prove lower
bounds is through combinatorial and
spectral analysis of random matrices and
unfortunately these are not really easy
lower bounds to prove
so back to the word cloud let's look at
another area that i'm interested in this
upper left area the combinatorics region
so
through these papers on some of squares
lower bounds we of course encounter some
interesting combinatorics mostly through
this like matrix valued fourier analysis
technique
and i've also worked on some other
related questions that came out uh so
here are two works
of mine that are actually both appearing
in this conference so maybe you saw the
talk i gave yesterday on the inner
product polynomials which is some really
fun combinatorial stuff that we
discovered
and then
another paper that i've worked on is an
approach to code upper bounds through
semi-definite programs and linear
programs
okay so that's that region i just want
to tell you about one more region which
is some new and exciting directions that
i think are a
field of future research which is this
lower right corner having to do with
statistical physics and average case
problems
so okay why do i find this very
interesting because if you
start to read the literature you find
that there's a lot of really incredible
predictions and algorithms for these
average case problems and for stuff like
random csps
and yeah one thing that we've been doing
is proving lower bounds that match these
predictions and trying to give
algorithms so i think there's a lot of
opportunity to connect the insights from
the different fields both on a technical
level and an intuitive level so here's
some future directions kind of studying
this stuff
um yeah i'll just put them here and
maybe explain them really quickly
so some of this powerful technology and
approximate message passing might have
to do with
other
technology more familiar to computer
scientists i'm also interested in some
walk-based surrounding algorithms and in
general can we understand the complexity
of certification tasks which is really
what sum of squares is doing
so yeah here's the word cloud again
thanks for listening um yeah looking for
postcard positions thanks
perfect thanks a lot uh chris uh next up
is david weitz uh at stanford uh please
feel free to share screen and start
whenever you're ready david
all right so you see my screen
yes yes
all right uh so as gautam said my name
is david weitz if you want to think
about how to pronounce that last name
think of the word invites and then drop
the in
i'm uh
cmu alumni
i uh alumnus i am currently a postdoc at
stanford and i'm looking for faculty
positions
so uh broadly construed i work on
algorithms let's quickly revisit our
classic view of algorithm design so
historically the way we think about
algorithms is you get an input you spit
out an output
and then you're done
unfortunately this view is becoming
increasingly antiquated for a number of
modern applications
where really you know you still have
your inputs but your output is very
often externalized to users who in turn
will keep generating more input to which
you need to respond so really what we
have here is evolving inputs and
evolving outputs
if you want to think of some motivating
applications where this is kind of the
dynamics
the gig economy is a good place to look
for this where we have a lot of uh
agents entering and leaving the platform
over time so for example in ride sharing
we have drivers and passengers entering
and leaving the platform same for uh
food delivery where food orders and food
couriers arrive over time
so all these modern applications give a
modern motivation to revisit the
following
key theoretical question which is how
should we react to evolving data how
should we maintain an evolving output in
the face of evolving inputs
and there's various theoretical models
that study this question so we can ask
how should we react if we have to react
immediately and irrevocably to the
changes in the input this is studied by
online algorithms we can also
ask what should we do if we want to
react quickly this is the area of
dynamic algorithms and finally we can
ask how do we react if we have to react
space efficiently which is the area of
streaming algorithms
so just to give you kind of a sampling
of some some of my work into space
uh some questions i like to think of
does randomization help
in the context of online matching and
those general settings you can think of
and unfortunately here the answer is no
another type of question is does
randomization help in the face of
adaptively changing inputs
and you should be thinking about this
feedback loop we had before the
algorithm externalizes an output to the
users who based on that decide what
changes to make to the input
and uh here there's a very strong
positive result and a generic framework
to design
dynamic matching algorithms that work
for adaptively changing inputs
finally in the context of streaming we
ask that the primal dual method is a
useful tool for submodular maximization
and here too the answer is yes
uh i guess we have another minute so let
me give you bonus bits i also have
interests in distributed algorithms so
for example we have this recent work on
the first universally optimal congest
algorithms for minimum spanning tree min
cut single source shortest path and the
like
also have some interest in networking
for example uh we had this uh joint work
a couple years ago on the separation
between routing and network coding for
multiple point-to-point communication
problems
uh all right so that's more or less my
time again i'm david weitz and i'm on
the faculty
job market reach out if you have any
questions
enjoy your day
perfect thanks so much david uh okay
we're going to swing back to alex block
uh if he's ready alex at purdue
can you see my screen
uh yeah we see your ipad with the movie
screen yeah go ahead you can see okay
awesome thank you so much sorry about
the technical difficulties from earlier
my name is alex block i'm phd candidate
at purdue university my advisor is
jeremiah blocky
uh i
am hopefully graduating this august and
i'm looking for a postdoc position
sometime early august or late august
early september
so my research mainly is in cryptography
and coding theory and you can break it
down into two main themes so the theme
one is that coding theory is useful for
cryptography and in my work um
i show new ways in which this is true so
for example coding theory is a key
component in optimal and an optimal
cryptographic object called correlation
extractors and it is implicit and
soundness of pcp-based interactive
arguments
my second theme is the reverse which is
cryptography is useful for coding theory
so cryptographic analysis techniques can
be used to simplify coding theory proofs
and cryptographic models and objects can
be used to give new and efficient code
constructions and very briefly i'm going
to talk in a bit more detail about what
are my main interests currently
so my first main interest is in space
efficient interactive arguments
so in prior work what we have done is we
construct space efficient interactive
arguments for np and then we can do
standard techniques to make it
non-interactive and zero knowledge and
our key idea was the streaming model
which is that you can generate the
transcript of a computation as a stream
by just running the computation for a
time step and basically encoding its
state
so we give constructions under both the
discrete log plus random oracle and the
unknown order assumptions and the prover
is essentially optimal in terms of time
and has some poly logarithmic space
overhead so this is great
and feature work in this space um i am
very interested in concrete
implementations of the above protocols
with uh performance analysis versus the
state-of-the-art zk snarks now available
also concrete security analysis of zk
snarks this is a very messy area and no
one's really tackled it but i think it
would be very interesting
and also applying techniques of the
above
of the above protocols to construct new
interactive arguments under different
assumptions for example lattices and
pairings
my second main interest is in locally
decodable codes for insertion deletion
errors this is a more general error
model where you can insert and delete
symbols from the code word and not just
do hamming errors
so in prior work we reprove a so-called
hamming to instill compiler of astros
game pesky and taranowski and the key
idea here was we use cryptographic
analysis techniques which are common to
the study of memory hard functions and
create a conceptually simpler and
cleaner proof this compiler basically
takes any hamming locally decodable code
and can turn it into a locally decodable
code secure against insertion deletion
errors
or resilient against that and then in a
follow-up work we extend this compiler
to quote-unquote cryptographic codes
what i mean by this
is for example in the case of private
locally decodable codes the encoder and
decoder share a private key this is a
cryptographic assumption or when you
assume that the channel is resource
bounded for example it's the channel can
only introduce errors as a ppt algorithm
or it has some space contracts
and feature work in this
in this area i want to be able to
know can we actually construct insertion
deletion ldcs without a compiler as far
as i know there's really
no results known like this and also
extend the compiler to other lbcs for
example relaxed ldcs computationally
relaxed lbcs other models
and yeah thank you that's all i have for
today uh and again i'm looking for
postdoc late august early september
perfect uh thanks alex uh if that's it
then we can move on to our final
presenter of the session who is once
again arielle schwartzman at
dimax
ariel
yep yeah
[Music]
uh okay i need to like give me a second
yep yep we we have a little bit of extra
time so you got some cushion
uh there we go can you see the screen
yeah we can see your screen yep good
thank you thanks everyone for the
patience it seems like there was some
windows update probably
classic all right yeah we can see go
ahead
all right thank you uh so my name is
ariel schwartzman i'm an alum from
princeton and i'm a dynamics now as a
postdoc
my work is an approximately optimal
mechanism in tournament design and i'm
looking for retainer track positions in
theory
so let me tell you about the canonical
problem mechanism design you might have
heard of this uh you know suppose we
have a seller on the right this man with
the blue uh shirt and there's a woman on
the left who wants to buy an apple she
has some private value for the apple
the seller does not know this value
but he knows it comes from some
distribution with cdff
and the question is how should he
price it so as to gain the maximal
revenue
in the presence of you know possibly
strategic behavior on the part of the
buyer
and it turns out that there's a very
simple solution for this problem uh
which is to just post a uh a single
posted price
given by the formula that i wrote on the
slide this is proven by meyerson roughly
40 years ago
uh a contribution for which among other
things you know he wanted about price
and economics
and it's a very nice algorithm it's
deterministic it's simple it's elegant
it's terrific
uh so you might ask okay what happens
when you're trying to sell more than one
fruit right so we have apples bananas
and pineapples uh what does the optimal
mechanism look like in this case and the
answer is we don't know uh after you
know roughly 40 years of research we
know that
multi-item optimal mechanisms are
complex they require randomization
they're not intuitive there's a myriad
of lower bounds that uh make you know
finding optimal mechanisms hard
and my work uh
revolves around you know circumventing
these lower bounds or trying to get
around them so the first way is you know
in the presence of
computational hardness results in
computer science what we tend to do is
we turn to approximation algorithms
and in our work we gave the first qp
test for a large classifiers
and q p tests for
more specific ones so we give better
approximation algorithms
another way to get around these lower
bounds is to study non-heterogeneous
items so part of the reason why it is
hard to sell bananas and apples and
pineapples is because they're very
incomparable
uh so we study
uh settings where you know we call them
partially ordered or totally ordered
items and we give a pitas for the
partially ordered item and we
characterize optimal mechanisms for the
totally ordered items uh another way
which we can overcome these
impossibility results is going beyond
worst case analysis a lot of the lower
bounds for mechanism design arise from
like very
uh pathological distributions
and so in joint work with co-authors we
initiated the study of smooth analysis
for mechanism design which has been you
know a very celebrated line of work for
uh algorithm design we're trying to
bring it over to mechanism design and
the last and most recent route is to
change the benchmark so in some sense uh
the one of the reasons why optimal
mechanisms are so complex is perhaps
because we give too much power to the
seller
and in recent work
we initiate the study of fine-grained uh
what we call by many mechanisms so this
is a line of work that started a couple
of years ago and we initiate the study
of like fine grain by many mechanisms to
prove that
a lot of the impossibility results
that normally would happen
fall apart
um so that's my work in mechanism design
you also noticed maybe at the start of
the slide i had a word that's a
tournament design which is uh easier to
understand so
you know there's a lot of motivation for
uh
these questions coming from like the
olympics and the world cup you know
there's all these like sports scandals
we hear about every now and then one the
most popular one is the women's diamonds
and doubles at the 2012 olympics in
london uh it was a cheating scandal
and so a natural question for mechanism
designers is
to ask if we can design strategy proof
tournaments that will always pick
reasonable teams and altman and
kleinberg answered this with a no a
couple of years ago
and so in our work which was featured in
itcs a couple of years ago we asked can
we design approximately strategy-proof
tournaments that will always pick
reasonable teams the answer is yes very
natural rules actually
uh satisfy strong properties and are
optimal
in terms of like how much manipulation
can happen
and
there's lower bands and connections to
other questions in social choice theory
there you can ask me about this is
offline uh in an ongoing work we are
trying to understand the effect of uh
teams being selfish uh and that is all i
have to say i wanted to thank you for
your time and thank again mark and g for
organizing this in part of you know all
of the participants of the session
yeah thanks uh arielle uh thanks for
your talk and again yes thank you to all
participants for being flexible and uh
willing to jump in when necessary we had
the highest density of talks this entire
itcs uh 14 talks within one hour so i'm
going to awkwardly give everyone a hand
of applause right here by myself you can
give one alright ariel's joining me too
uh you can everyone else can get one on
mute at home if you want but yeah if you
want to see the lineup of speakers again
in case you missed anyone then uh check
out the website this session is recorded
in case you want to check anyone's talk
again and there's actually going to be
another session tomorrow at 9 30 a.m
with a shorter one with only 11 speakers
so please come back for that if you're
interested thanks a lot everyone for
joining and participating thank you
that's well done
yeah
everyone was very flexible i'm i'm
impressed uh even with some technical
difficulties we could jump in so well
done everyone
that's a lot tomorrow
yep